the pipe part of the culture of Polish
and Geocities if you are doing something
serious if you are involved in that
changes in the country you should be
open for such cooperation after several
years of such cooperation the the
granita a broad group was formed this is
the platform of Polish ng offices which
are working abroad the kinds of
coalition first to work internally with
members to establish standards but on
the other hand to work with other
institutions later I will say a few
words about the cooperation with
Minister of Foreign Affairs how NGOs is
in Poland tied to influence minister of
Polish at first the first activity of
this platform was to establish guiding
principles of Polish non-government
organisation working about kind kind of
ethical code and we can read in this
code the people organization and the
local communities with which we
cooperate in the East are our partners
as partners they have derived to know
and understand the essence of a joint
projects we make every effort that our
programs are conducted in conducted in
the language of the participants we
limit the use of international languages
to a million and finally what was their
action to the very limited number of
organizations which we were thinking
about cressey which we are thinking
about the past we built understanding
across borders for US citizens of
Belarus Lithuania and Ukraine at the
host of the countries we want to support
them in activities to establish
democracy independence and
John economic in the economic in the
Hamptons when we are thinking about
areas of cooperation above the geography
we could expect that the Western Ukraine
will be the area of possible conflict
that should be the most difficult to
establish links then no it's not true
determination to cooperation
determination to to to work together or
stronger in the past to say openly the
past is not a subject for the high
majority of the NGOs and talking about
oh they do not allow the past to they
remember about the past but they do not
allow to push the presence by the past a
lot of Polish non-government
organization have partners in reef even
randy's wooster knob you but also the
small towns even sometimes villages like
novena have partnership with some polish
communities of opposition Joseph's the
second area are which is the area of the
cooperation between Poland and Ukraine
is Kenya Kenya relationship between
polishing jobs and came into tasks from
the moment when they came back from the
portation and they came back to Ukraine
the polish Angie offices were among
those who helped came into task to build
Crimean Tatar schools which helped them
to be linked with their educators in
western Ukraine and went quite often to
open it classes of Ukrainian language
in the Crimean Tatar National Schools
finally in last four years we see that
more and more more and more interests
about cooperation between partners from
eastern Ukraine and Poland something
what was a break to was bri asked the
barians which few years ago invited
several police and officers to work with
new to work with local NGO seized in the
coke